good evening ladies and gentlemen thank
you very much for being here it is my
pleasure to introduce Secretary of
Defense Lloyd Austin III and chairman of
the Joint Chiefs Joint Chiefs of Staff
General Mark milley the secretary and
the chairman will provide some brief
opening remarks and then we'll have a
few minutes to take some questions I
will moderate those questions and call
on the reporters and I would ask you to
limit your follow-up since we do have a
limited amount of time today and I
appreciate your assistance with this Mr
secretary over to you sir thanks Pat
well good afternoon everyone
we've made excellent progress at our
sixth meeting of the Ukraine defense
contact group
and we were joined by my good friend
olexie resnikov
Ukraine's minister of defense
and by Major General
Ukraine's Joint Forces Commander
I'm very grateful to them for joining us
and for their heroic leadership
they updated the contact group on the
latest battlefield Dynamics
on Ukraine's priority needs
and on Ukraine's requirements to defend
itself
for the Long Haul
I'm also very pleased that ministers and
Chiefs of Defense from some 50 countries
took part in today's discussion
then again underscores the resolve of
the International Community
to support Ukraine's self-defense
after Russia's cruel and unprovoked
invasion
and that resolve has only been
heightened by the deliberate cruelty
of Russia's new barrage against Ukraine
cities
those assaults on targets with no
military purpose
again reveal the malice of Putin's war
of choice
but Russia's atrocities have further
United the nations of Goodwill that
stand with Ukraine
so we are here
because rules matter
because rights matter
and because sovereignty matters
and in the past few days Putin has given
us all
another Grim preview of a future
in which the appetites of aggressive
autocrats outweigh the rights of
peaceful States
we would all be less secure
in a world where big powers can assault
their peaceful neighbors and trample
their borders by force
and the free citizens of Ukraine have an
inalienable right
to govern themselves
and to choose their own future
they underpin
oh these are Bedrock principles and they
underpin the rules-based international
order that makes us all more secure
this contact group will stay true to
those values
regardless of the outcome of any
individual battle
and we will not waver in our support for
UK Ukraine's right to defend itself
from Russia's Imperial ambitions
Ukraine's forces
have used systems like high Mars to
change the Dynamics of the war that
Putin started
and that's helped Ukrainian forces seize
the initiative during their
counter-offensive
so we'll continue to rush in the
capabilities to help Ukraine in the
current fight
and I commend the contact group members
who have moved Heaven and Earth
to get weapons and equipment into the
hands of the Ukrainian forces
at the same time our allies and partners
are driving hard
to sustain Ukraine's Defenders for the
Long Haul
as a conflict has evolved
the mission of this contact group has
evolved as well
so today the contact group underscored
our shared commitment to keep on
supplying Ukraine's Defenders with the
capability that they will need in the
difficult weeks months and years ahead
we discuss ways to
do even more to train Ukrainian forces
who are making such impressive use of
their new capabilities
and we push to Galvanize our industrial
bases
to fire up production for the systems to
defend Ukraine
even while meeting our own security
needs
the leaders here built on the important
progress from the September 28th meeting
of our national armaments directors
under the auspices of this contact group
Denmark and the UK shared updates on
several Copenhagen conference
initiatives
including the UK's International donors
fund for pooling International funding
for critical capabilities
and as we increase our long-term support
for Ukraine
transparency and accountability remain
crucial
at today's meeting we discuss the
accountability measures Ukraine is using
to ensure that advanced weapons are
fully tracked
we also discuss ways to work together to
build on our momentum
and to meet new challenges
we know that Ukraine still needs even
more long-range fires
in air defense systems and artillery
systems
along with other crucial capabilities
and I'm grateful to our many allies and
partners who have raced to meet
Ukraine's self-defense needs
often pulling from their own stocks or
purchasing capabilities from domestic
industry
let me especially commend Germany for
its recent delivery
of an Irish T air defense system
this critical donation will help Ukraine
better defend its civilians from Russian
airstrikes
and Germany also recently announced that
it would deliver more Mars rocket
systems and howriters
and all that shows long-term support for
Ukraine's Defenders
I want to also recognized several
countries doing especially important
work together to ramp up production on
Key Systems and reinvigorate their
industrial basis
and so Norway Germany and Denmark have
all invested in Slovakia's homegrown
production of howitzers
and that just shows how much we can do
when we come together in common purpose
these initiatives and many more will
help us build momentum and ensure that
the future Ukrainian armed forces are
capable
and
have the ability to sustain themselves
now some countries aren't in a position
to offer lethal assistance
but we urge them to provide vital
non-lethal AIDS such as medical supplies
and cold weather gear that the
ukrainians need to fight in the winter
because every contribution counts
and the members of this contact group
Stand United in our support for
Ukraine's self-defense
through any season
We Stand United
by our commitment to the rules-based
international order that underpins
Global Security
We Stand United against the deliberate
use of war and atrocity to
seize territory redraw borders and
trample The Sovereign rights of peaceful
States
and as President Biden has said We Stand
United against the global politics of
fear coercion and Conquest
thank you and I'll turn it over to
General milley for his opening comments
thanks secretary Austin and uh thank you
for your steadfast leadership this
contact group who would not even be in
existence without the leadership of
secretary Austin and also uh want to
thank Ukrainian Minister defense and
especially also who's not here uh
General zaluzny my counterpart in
Ukraine for leading the Ukrainian
military in their efforts for their
freedom I maintain contact with him two
to three times a week General Cavalli
even more than that and of course our
staffs are in contact on a day-to-day
basis I also want to thank all the
ministers and the chiefs of defense that
were here at this meeting today
representing 50 countries that's an
incredible statement of resolve and
international support for the freedom of
Ukraine and I am confident that this
group will stay together for as long as
it takes today as secretary pointed out
this group met for the sixth time with
senior representatives from each of
these countries and it's a testament to
our condemnation Collective condemnation
the international condemnation of the
illegal invasion of Ukraine by Russia
this fight is not just in Ukraine's
interest
it is in the global interest to protect
as the secretary pointed out the
rules-based international order and that
is our purpose that has been given to us
the uniform military from our civilian
leadership which is to uphold the
rules-based international order that was
established from 80 years ago at the
conclusion of World War II
and our end state is equally clear
it is to ensure that Ukraine remains a
free independent Sovereign Nation
and the ways and means
that we are doing that is through
security Force assistance with lethal
and non-lethal Aid
in order to enable Ukraine to fight for
themselves
Ukraine is not asking for soldiers from
any other country
the ukrainians are willing to fight for
themselves all they ask for is the means
to do it and as President Biden has said
in many other national leaders have said
we will do as much as we can for as long
as we can and we will do as much as it
takes for as long as it takes
this contact group remains critical
to the mission of supplying Ukraine with
the capabilities
they need to fight for their country
and this war
is a war of choice a war of Choice by
Russia
and Russia is paying an extremely high
cost
a high cost in human life and casualties
and weapons material
and in their economy each day
that this war goes on
costs Russia more and more
and the Russian people begin to suffer
Russia has chosen in response to
escalate
with a recent mobilization of three
hundred thousand call-ups for constraint
for conscripts
they have tried to conduct an illegal
annexation of four of the oblas in
occupied Ukraine
they have increased their rhetoric
to include rhetoric about nuclear
weapons
and of course in the past few days
Russia has increased their strikes on
civilian infrastructure power generation
and dams
Russia has deliberately struck
civilian infrastructure with the purpose
of harming civilians
they have targeted the elderly the women
and the children of Ukraine
indiscriminate and deliberate attacks
on civilians targets
is a war crime in the international
rules of War
Ukraine and its citizens have suffered
greatly
but the people in the nation of Ukraine
endure and they are an inspiration to
all
the Nations gathered here today are
committed to the assisting
Ukraine defend itself
Ukraine continues to fight with bravery
and honor and the Ukraine military is
making continued progress as you see in
their counteroffensives in the donaste
kharkiv kirison luhansk and elsewhere
Ukrainian military has fought
extraordinarily well
and the discussions at this contact
group today
were about meeting Ukraine's current
needs and also supporting them in the
Long Haul
we focused on air defense on Canon
artillery rocket artillery maneuver
tanks infantry fighting Vehicles armored
personnel carriers also discuss training
in a wide variety of non-lethal support
these systems and the associated
ammunition are critical
for Ukraine to continue the fight
and they are employing these weapons
extremely well
so I'll stop there and I thank you and
welcome your questions Mr secretary
chairman thank you very much our first
question will go to John Ismail New York
Times
getting remarks today you said quote our
resolve to support Ukraine's Defenders
extends through all seasons unquote with
winter fast approaching do you expect
them to do you expect the Ukrainian
Armed Forces to continue fighting to
retake their territory throughout the
season until spring
thanks John um the battlefield remains
Dynamic and uh winter always presents a
challenge when it comes to fighting but
the the International Community remains
United and focused uh and and committed
to doing everything that we can to help
Ukraine
protect its interest and defend its
Sovereign territory
I expect that Ukraine will continue to
do everything it can throughout the
winter to uh to regain its uh its
territory and to uh and to be effective
on the battlefield and we're going to do
everything we can to make sure that they
have what what's required to be
effective and uh most recently we've
seen them be very effective both in the
East and down in the South as they've
taken back uh quite a bit of territory
from the Russians so we can expect that
that type of activity will continue on
through the winter
let's go to you Deborah Haynes Sky News
thank you very much
um a British spy Chief this week said
that Russia is one running out of
weapons how concerned are you though
about Western stockpiles and whether
Western weapons could run out first and
specifically on air defense systems
given the need from Ukraine why are
Western allies not sending these systems
in Faster is it because of a lack of
political will or a lack of supplies
well certainly is not a question of lack
of will
the commitment the resolve that the
chairman and I witnessed in this contact
group meeting today
was inspiring and that's what I told the
members of the group they they remain
committed to doing everything they can
to generate additional capabilities and
you heard me say at the top that several
countries have are working together to
expand capacity in in their industrial
base and I think it's that kind of
initiative that kind of activity that
will create other opportunities for us
as we go forward we we talked about air
defense the requirement for additional
air defense capabilities and countries I
have every confidence that countries
will do whatever they can if they can to
uh to generate additional capabilities
you've heard us talk about providing
naysams
and uh and that's gonna that's good
capability it's gonna going to really
help the ukrainians you heard heard me
say earlier that Germany is providing an
rst system and again we I expect to see
more capability come we saw some
additional countries volunteer to
provide Munitions for the those nasam
systems today and that that that's
always encouraging and refreshing so uh
the the will is certainly there to uh to
do everything we can for as long as we
can and the commitment again was
inspiring
let's go to Sylvia lantamount agency
France press
thank you Mr secretary after President
Putin's threat about nuclear use of
nuclear weapons you said repeatedly that
you have seen nothing that would cause
you to change your nuclear posture will
you communicate when you when this
posture changes and uh chairman I have a
question for you too
um we spoke about air defense as a
priority and the Nations and the German
Irish tea that have to be ordered to the
industry but it's urgent so in the
meantime are there other systems maybe
older systems that the allies of Ukraine
could find faster
so
um
let me Begin by saying Sylvie that
Putin's saber rallying is reckless
nuclear saber rattling is reckless and
irresponsible we don't expect to to see
and hear that kind of behavior from a
major nuclear power and so that's very
dangerous and you've heard a number of
leaders around the world emphasize that
you should know and I know you do
that we take this very seriously and
this is something that we remain focused
on and we continue to watch indicators
uh indications and any type of warning
that that he may have made a decision to
go uh in a different direction we've not
seen any indicators at this point that
would lead us to believe that but again
it's not something we look at once and
leave alone this is something we remain
focused on 24 hours a day seven days a
week
so silly
um put it in context a little bit
what Ukraine is asking for and and what
uh we think can be provided is an
integrated air missile defense system
um so that doesn't control all the air
space over Ukraine but they're designed
to control priority targets that Ukraine
needs to protect and what you're looking
at really is short range low altitude
systems and then medium range medium
altitude and then long range and high
altitude systems and it's a mix of all
of these that deny the airspace to
Russian aircraft fixed Wing or rotoring
aircraft and Russian missile defense
right so that's what you're trying to
create you're trying to create a
defensive system so far Ukraine is very
effectively used their essay sixes and
eights s 300s and STD 10 11s Etc so
they've been very effective at denying
Russian air superiority and that in turn
has denied the Russians the ability to
conduct ground combined arms maneuver uh
so what what needs to be done here by
all of the various countries that were
at the conference today is chip in and
help them
rebuild and and sustain an integrated
air and missile defense system
specifically older systems like you were
just asking about uh Ukraine has asked
for hawk or improved talk ihoc as it's
called that's a medium altitude medium
range system it's an older system but
it's quite effective and and there's
other systems out there uh throughout
you know throughout the world that that
are available many countries have
Patriot many countries uh have other
systems there's a whole series of
Israeli systems that are quite capable
the Germans have systems as we mentioned
so a lot of the countries that were here
today have a wide variety of systems uh
and and the the task will be to bring
those together get them deployed get
them trained because each of these
systems is different make sure that they
can link together with a command and
control and communication systems and
make sure they have Radars that can talk
to each other so that they can acquire
Targets on the inbound flights so it's
it's quite complicated from a technical
standpoint it is achievable and that's
what we're aiming at
me it'll take a little bit that's right
thank you sir our final question we'll
go to Vladimir ruinets from ictv
thank you for this opportunity uh I'm
one of those who uh this Monday just
this Monday wasn't sure that I would be
able to be here because of the
airstrikes that we experienced in Kiev
and the the question I'm going to ask is
not mine is the it's the
people people of Ukraine would like to
ask you when will they be able to just
sleep well and not be afraid to leave
their families behind and go on a trip
like this because I'm really I'm here
and I'm really
anxious about what is happening to my
family back home so when are the systems
going to be provided and is there a
possibility that the sky is going to be
safe
uh the short answer to your question sir
is the systems will be provided as fast
as we can physically get them there and
this is something as I said at the top
that we remain focused on uh and uh
we're going to provide
systems uh that that we have available
that countries like Germany has
available we're also going to try to
provide additional Munitions to the
existing systems that the that the
Ukrainian forces are using as long as
there's a the conflict goes on there
will always be uncertainty so it's very
difficult to predict when it's exactly
when it's going to be safe to to move
about move in and out of the country and
I know that you're concerned about your
family uh and and you've and you
certainly that's that's understandable
but we're going to do everything we can
as fast as we can to help the Ukrainian
forces get the capability they need to
protect the Ukrainian people that's very
very important to us and and by the way
it was important to all the 50 members
that were on that were in that meeting
today and their Chiefs of Defense uh and
this is uh I mean the utility of this
this Ukraine defense contact group I
just can't uh I can't over emphasize how
how useful this is because it helps us
to address Uh current near-term problems
and mobilize resources much faster than
we otherwise would be able to and again
I don't want to over I don't want to
exaggerate this point but I have to tell
you that I I remain impressed by the
commitment of the of the members of the
group and for the most part these are
ministers of defense that show up to
every meeting and not uh not surrogates
so
foreign
I'm afraid that's all the time that we
have available for today Mr secretary
chairman thank you very much ladies and
gentlemen appreciate it
this concludes our press briefing